It's important to realise that the gliders are designed
according to the rules and the scoring the rule have a very
high impact on the way we fly as a competitor and the way we
design as a designer. If the legislators decide that
any competition should be raised on ENC wings, then the
manufacturer will produce very specific ENC wings, and it
doesn't mean that someone which was happily flying an ENC wing
before will be able to fly this ENC competition wings.
Do you guys still discuss making Enzo 3 better or is this more or
less like Enzo 4 is only possible if the sport sees a
paradigm shift in its paperwork 1st and then the designers will
get to. Work.
We're trying to do an Enzo for whatever are the rules.
We are working since maybe five years and we're trying to make
progress every glider, otherwise we don't release.
Hello and welcome back to Paragliding After Us.
I'm your host, Aninda Singh. And joining us today is the man
himself, Luke Armand. Luke, this has been a long time
coming. Welcome to the show.
Thank you Luke. I want to dive right in and, you
know, compare let's say 2011's situation to 2025.
The industry has seen fair bit of evolution over the past
years, but a debate or a safety debate, as Gavin called in his
show has raged on once again. And back in 2011, we had sports
class, which was deemed to be too dangerous or open class,
which was deemed to be too dangerous.
And people said that we need a reform of some sorts.
Fast forward to 2025. We have put in all the, you
know, time, energy and money in making wings safer and more fun.
And yet we are standing at the same question once again.
So from your eyes, who has seen the industry evolve?
Is this something different, or is this just history repeating
itself all over again? No, I don't think the history
repeats. Things are evolving, but we keep
having accidents but we try to progress.
I mean everyone, manufacturers, but also obviously organisers.
By those everything, I mean we're doing fantastic sport
there. We're having a lot of fun.
It's it's really great. It's a great, great sport.
But unfortunately sometimes there is some accidents and so
we can only try to get things better.
Fair enough. Luke, if we have to look at the
main reasons why open class had to go away, is it something
similar to the reasons that are being called out for the too
much focus on performance versus too little focus on safety?
Because I think Kriegel came up with a statement a few days ago
said that we tend to focus on one aspect when that one is
weighing heavy and the other aspect takes a back seat.
But then when we reach a period where we don't see that many,
you know, mishaps or something and then we just go back to
chasing safety. So what's your point of view on
this? There are several things on your
question, but it's true that the community is reacting to events.
It's very difficult to have the community anticipating things.
So it's when there are some accidents, there are some
reactions. If there is no accident and some
people warn for whatever possible problems, usually there
is no reaction until a problem comes.
That's the way things are. And 2011 there has there was a
spectacular problem because two fatality in the first task of
the words and from there there was a reaction and and move.
And then we also look at something to play with accident
because we only kind of count fatal accidents for some
reasons. And well, the sport is accepted
a lot more broken bones of course than fatal accidents.
But there has been a long period without too much fatal
accidents. And we were community was happy.
But at the last words there was 1 fatal accident and all the
fatal accident of the competitions.
And so there is a reaction which is which is a fair reaction to
try to improve things. So there was also a question
about open class. I can clarify that, you know.
Yeah, yeah. But I can answer, I think open
class was obviously missing a little bit of testing from some
manufacturers and there was some sometimes some not so good
behaviour in some gliders that was responsible for really some
accident pilot couldn't do anything about.
But there was also other things that has been corrected.
It's not only the gliders. At that time final glide was
very dangerous. It's important to realise that
gliders are designed according to the rules and the scoring.
The scoring is very important and at that time you were not
having so much leading points, mostly time points.
And you, you could every minute, if I remember well, you could
gain 30 time points. On top of that, the competition
with the two fatalities on the first task was happening in
which is very lifty era with convergence and the final glide
was in convergence. So we're talking of final glide
with excess altitude and final glide with excess altitude.
If you just go to a cylinder, there is no brain to have.
You just need to go as fast as possible.
There is no Mac ready anymore, nothing.
You just go as fast as possible and you earn maybe 25 or 30
points per minute when one point can make a difference in the
overall of the competition. So the format make was making a
really big push for the glider to have absolute top speed
without so much testing dreamers on the risers.
So a lot of ingredients to create accidents.
Fair enough. I think that is a very common
analogy which is used in aviation in general, that it
does not take one mess up which contributes to the mishap
eventually. It's a it's a combination of
things which lead us there. But I think you touched upon a
very important point there where you mentioned that how we fly
depends a lot about legislation and the scoring and how we push
the limits. So more or less, if I have to
narrow this down for easier understanding of our audiences,
are we not having enough learned people in the sport who want to
sit down and do the boring part? Because regardless, anybody who
gets pushed into the sport is coming in for the joy of flight
and legislation, paperwork and all the, you know, bookkeeping
is usually done by people who are not so or in a professional
manner who are not so much into outdoor extreme adventure sports
or something. Whereas our sport is mostly
consisting of pilots who are picking up various roles.
So do you see a lack of skilled brainpower sitting down and
saying that I want to work towards this?
Or is this just evolution taking its own course, more or less?
I don't think so. I think there, there is a lot of
good brains working on the rules and scoring and stuff, but it
needs some drive. I mean a lot of these guy, they
are also pilots, passionated pilots.
I also tried to spend a bit of my working time on on the
subject, participate some expert group and give some technical
inputs. But it's also difficult to get
things working efficiently in in some groups because you need to
agree it's good to have a lot of brain working together, but it
needs also some efficiency in the debate and some some
leadership. And it's difficult to organise
things. But CCC has been created, the
scoring has evolved, the things are evolving in a good manner.
It takes time, but these sort of things I think can only take
time. OK.
I want to take the example of Ozone.
We have seen a lot of brands come and go in the industry.
Legacy brands are few, but the ones who exist are more or less
cementing their place as the time goes on.
Mostly brands have been started, as you said that you know, we
are a bunch of passionate pilots.
So somebody is like, OK, I want to start make a living out of
this. I'll go out and put my own brand
and invest in R&D and collect the team.
So Ozone has done a lot of things right to come as one of
the top contenders when it comes to wing choice.
And I believe Ozone needed a lot of paperwork, a lot of R&D and a
lot of other things that contribute to the success
eventually. So if FAI or civil or any of
these, you know, the the companies or maybe even European
norms if they were run commercially like the brand, is
there more chances of success? Because I think money is a big
problem that anybody who's coming in is doing it more or
less out of passion and not out of profit.
Yes, but you know, like the World Cup, for example, is, is
a, is a kind of company, it's a non profit company, but it needs
to to not lose money. So the organisers, all the
organisers, they need to organise things.
They do that not for earning money.
Most of them is for the passion as well.
Uh but they need to organise the things efficiently so they don't
lose money. Don't know if that's answering
your question, maybe I haven't understood it.
Correctly. It's, it's, it's basically like,
are we not having professional structures in place enough that
invite the right people? More or less because Ozone had a
professional structure based on, let's say, the model of
capitalism and they succeeded in surviving where other brands
eventually lost out on the race. So if Ozone can do it when it
comes to commercializing the, the, the selling part, then why
can't we professionalize the structure when it comes to
managing the sport? That is my dilemma here.
OK. I think it's quite professional
in a way that the organiser are in competition.
I mean if you speak about capitalism, organisers are in
competition in a way. So they they are pushed to do a
good job. I don't blame organiser or Cava
or stuff like that. They everything can be more
efficient and but there are some feedbacks, there are some
competition. There was a time where PWVC was
in competition with the area and they were pushing each other.
At the moment it's kind of the same leading team, which also
gives some advantages because everything can be equal in the
scoring and. Let's talk about the legislation
a bit. You know, I think as you
mentioned that it the way sport evolves is a lot about how the
rules are set. Rules do change, but not up to a
large extent. Are we, are we lacking
tightening of rules at a lower level which eventually leads to
this kind of an attitude once we reach the professional levels or
what is kind of lacking that allows us to make machines which
are really fun, really cool to fly, but when they go bad, they
go really bad. And sometimes the the cost that
we pay is is the highest possible one.
About holes, you you talking about Section 7?
Not just that, also the guidelines that manufacturers
have to adhere to, because, regardless, it is the European
norms based on which the equipment is being produced.
Section 7, of course, has its own importance when it comes to
racing, but more or less the. Ecosystem of rules, yeah.
So there are many things behind rules here you have European
norm which is driven by European administration with a group of
experts trying to make it evolve and it takes time.
There is the Section 7 which includes the the CCC rules and
all the scoring things. This is a big book of rules for
competition driven by CIBA and there is a PWVC rules which also
is in accordance with Section 7 anyway mostly.
But all these rules have to be manipulate with a lot of
cautious because it's very difficult to anticipate the
consequences of any change of these rules.
And so often the people writing these rules, they want to try
test before really applying them because they may have some good
effect and they may have some side effect that you don't know
and it's difficult to anticipate.
So there is a lot of debate of experts and some testing before
a rule is is set a a change is set.
So you mean prototyping of some sorts?
Basically when you guys come out with a new product, you
prototype it and then you know, do a hit and try method.
And that is kind of lacking over here, that we don't have a
foolproof method where we can test the success of rules and
the only way is to go out and keep on going ahead with the
challenges that we face like it. It just seems a very lost case.
And and in that regard that we don't know which rule will work,
but we can only keep on trying. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, the, the, the rules are tested and they
eventually are changed, you know, yeah, norms is changing
like every two or three years. Section 7 is changing every
year. A lot of details like way of
calculation in the end of speed in in leading points.
CCC rules are also evolving. There is a lot of debate now,
but the rule have a very high impact on on the way we fly as a
competitor and on the way we design as a designer.
But this effect is very difficult to anticipate.
Let's talk about ENC class. It's not that long ago that the
whole class saw revolution of some sorts.
From your perspective, who has seen the sport go from open to
triple to triple C down to There was a time when END's were
considered as the go to gliders for a lot of pilots and now
almost nobody's talking about END.
So how did ENC class get its significance and why do we
suddenly see a whole new level of performance being pushed onto
a lower category of glider that was never meant to be raced?
It was just a cross country machine for pilots who were
looking not to increase the bar too high but still have the fun.
Yeah. So yeah, a bit of history here.
We had open class after Piedra ETA 2011, it was END.
The reaction was to forbid open class and glad you need to have
an EN. So the manufacturers they
produced, the first competition was done with existing ENDS and
then the manufacturers did specific design END for
competition because manufacturers wanted to win
competitions and this specific design were nothing to do with
the previously existing ENDS. And for example, in Ozone, we
had the Montra Air 04 and we produce 4 competition, a wing
called Enzo, which was based on our open class, slightly
modified to pass END norm. But we were still selling the
END for leisure pilots, the targeted pilots that we had
doing cross country experience, cross country pilots.
And at the same time we were selling the competition END
glider. But this was putting a lot of
confusion in the market because the the people they had the idea
that EN stamp is, is a way to to know what glider is for them.
So they there is a pilot flying E&D wing and he thinks his level
is for flying E&D wings, whatever the manufacturer says.
But the reality is not like that.
END is not is just a big guarantee of some testing, but
the product is targeted for from you.
You should know what the manufacturer says about the
public target. But because the there is this
confusion with yen and the target public, a lot of people
were buying competition gliders where they they didn't have the
label for that. So there was a that was one of
the reason there was all the reason behind, but I don't want
to develop too much for creating the CCC.
So basically it was a class of competition with some specific
rule, easy to apply for competition and testing.
So I'm guarantee of some behaviours, flight testing.
So regarding ENC wings, it's exactly the same story as E&D.
If the legislators decide that any competition should be raised
on ENC wings, then the manufacturer will produce very
specific ENC wings for competition.
And it doesn't mean that someone which was happily flying an ENC
wing before will be able to fly this ENC competition wings.
This competition wings will be if it's, if you apply just only
ENC as a as a criteria, this competition wings will be maybe
an aspect ratio of eight and some really high performance
features that will be only suitable for top pilots.
So it's important to always, it's always the story of rules
and side effect of rules. You can say the any NC current
ENC wing like the photon is great.
I'm I'm making so nice cross country with it.
It's so great to race with it. Why don't we make all
competition with ENC then? So we have all this sort of
gliders to race with and it would be super safe and fun.
But when you do that, you don't anticipate for the next
generation glider because you have to understand that every
manufacturer is in is in competition.
I don't want to put you in a spot Luke, because yeah,
probably you know there are some responsibilities that come when
you are associated with the industrial leading brand like
Ozone. But help me understand this, how
are we not sabotaging the E&C class as we did with the E&D
class back in the day? Because right now there is not a
single pilot out in the market who would want to go out and put
their money on a three liner E&C simply because of the image that
a three liner versus 2 liner has.
And when the majority of the field is going out and getting a
better glide in A2 liner and getting faster speed in A2
glider, everyone is going to just go in for two liner ENC.
And to me this is clearly history repeating itself, but in
a different class altogether. And right now I understand that
we are focusing on triple CS because the noise and the anger
or like the this conversation is in that regard.
But I see this thing coming back to sports class in like the, the
kickback will come in a in a couple of years and, and it will
be ugly and it will be messy. And we will be scratching our
heads that what did we not learn that we are in this position all
over again. Uh, first, ENC is existing since
a long time and it's not going crazy if it's not using
competition, where competition results as an important for
manufacturers to promote themselves, then manufacturers
interest is only to have a glider that is suitable for
market the target. So when you target a specific
market, I would say like pilot, like flying 100 hours a year
doing this sort of cross country.
This is a pilot I want to target and I want them to have a good
wing for sure, a performant wing, but a wing where they
don't crash themselves with. Because if I design A glider
where that is very, very competitive, very performant,
but the target pilots are crashing a lot with this, then I
just fire a bullet in my own foot.
As a manufacturer, it it's a very, it would be like maybe few
months term, bad calculation. You maybe you sell a little bit
at the start, but then the the glider has very bad reputation.
Your brand has a very bad reputation.
You don't sell it anymore. So that's the reason why ENC
gliders are I think stayed reasonably in their target in
term of safety since a few years ago.
I mean maybe 10 years or 15 years, but now if you start
trying to promote your glider with competition results where
the competition use top pilots, which means pilots able to fly
difficult wings, then manufacturer will have interest
in making difficult to fly gliders but competitive.
So SLS, for example, is we see SLS with a bit of worry because
it's, it's it's a way to promote gliders as a manufacturer.
You could say, oh, look, my, my glider is doing so much good
result. It's a it's a good glider.
You should buy this one. While maybe the guys doing the
the good result are top pilots, expert, able to fly and very
skilled and then that would be problematic even though you
could say as a manufacturer. So the same story as the India
was explaining, you could say, OK, this glider has won the
competition but it's not for you, it's CNC, but it's not for
you. And a lot of pilot, they won't
hear that. They would, they would only hear
it's CNC and they would buy it. So that's that's where a
solution could be to create a proper sport class that has his
own criteria on top of him or separately for for.
Me. Makes sense, you know, Before I
move on to the next topic, Luke, this has been at the back of my
head, and I'm pretty sure there are a few pilots in the audience
as well. Like maybe not the racing ones,
maybe not the ones who are already having WPRS points and
rankings in their name, but let's talk about a 50 hour
pilot. Let's talk about someone who has
passed his school, invested his savings because I mean, you
know, it takes quite a lot of money to get to 50 hours in the
sport. Now, can you possibly be ready
for A2 liner enc after 50 to 70 hours on A&B?
Or is this a fool's paradise that all of our community is
willingly keeping their eyes shut at?
I wouldn't point things into liner like 2 liner, three liner,
things like that. I mean two liner doesn't mean so
much. There are huge different in
design between Denzo 3 and D5. For example a D5 is not more
difficult to handle than a D4 which is 3 liner in the centre.
The delta 5 is 2 liner so. But there are a lot of
parameters for the for the design that are not called in
any way. The only thing that we look is
how many risers there are on the bottom, but it doesn't really
point too much about what is the reality of this glider.
I mean in term of behaviour. So I would say yes it's
possible. It may also be possible to have
an ENB to liner that is easy to fly and suitable for someone 50
hours, but this cannot happen at the moment because ENB is not
allowed without collapse lines for some reason.
I could explain, but we don't have time.
Help me understand this Luke, Is human brain capable of handling
A2 liner Ena one day? Because if two liner is going to
become the norm of the society then why aren't we starting
pilots on 2 liners so that the inherent feeling which we
develop from the beginning is on A2 liner?
Why do we even have 3 liners anymore?
I explained 3 liner cannot be produced or certified without
collapse. Plan.
Accept that part. Let's let's forget.
The legislation for me, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But then you you shouldn't be too much focused on how many
liner here. But you're right about the
feeling for example, things are evolving with a more more and
more riser control with some pulleys.
So the feeling could become even like paracaid, you know the
moustache, there are three liners but the feeling is like 2
liners. It's a direct control of the
risers. But it's very different thing
because there is no accelerator. You do everything with your
hands. But you could have an Enbe with
speed system like classic paraglider.
When you go full speed you have the similar things as a park
height and that could be fun. But of course a moustache is not
for a beginner or park height engineer and Ena.
You could try to optimize the line drag for some schools.
They like to have more glide ratio for the student for the
same behaviour as if the glider is still very forgiving as a as
a glider for beginners in schools.
So it's possible to have Ena with better performance, maybe 2
liners or whatever solutions as as long as they are table for
beginners. Let's talk a little bit about
test reports. Luke, I'm I'm pretty sure this
is kind of common amongst all most of the brands that when you
usually go a category up. And I've seen specifically for
Zeno in in ozone that there is only one or two letters and
mostly in accelerated asymmetric, which makes it jump
to the next class. So if you were to pick up a wing
for yourself or like let's say a good friend, which specific test
result would you want a person to look at before making their
decision? I would say don't look at any
specific result. Don't look, just look at what
the manufacturers is saying about this glider.
What is the target pilot for this glider?
And that's what we, we should look as a, as a customer because
all these manufacturers around they are just telling the truth
about what, what the glider is for, who is it for?
And this result about collapses and things, they're not really
telling you so much about the glider.
Let's let's come back to Enzo for a SEC.
Luke, you know, we're, I know we're running out of time, so
I'll have to keep my questions short.
Enzo 3 has been pretty much unchallenged and at the top of
status quo for closing in on decade.
I think eight years or eight or nine years, something like that
when you guys came out with that design. 2017 so yeah.
Yep, right. So right now, is there, like, do
you guys still discuss making Enzo 3 better or is this more or
less like, yeah, you know, fits in the norms?
We have pushed it as much as we could and now Enzo 4 is only
possible if the sport sees a paradigm shift in its paperwork
1st and then the designers will get to work.
That's a good question. But no, we're trying to do an
Enzo 4, whatever the rules are doing and we are working since
maybe five years on the Enzo 4. And then we're trying to make
progress every glider. Otherwise we don't release.
And it needs to be in every aspect.
You can make progress in one aspect like torque, speed, but
then a sacrifice in another aspect like syncret or
behaviour. But we want something that is
globally better and it's quite difficult.
So we haven't succeed our criteria for the moment, but we
we're still working hardly on the subject at the moment.
That's so exciting to hear any any tentative, you know, let's
say date that you guys discuss amongst yourself when you're
sitting in the in the office. I was like.
Dates we try to decide to to discuss and sometime we give
information. It's been like 3 or 4 times that
we say to the pilot maybe next year we have an Enzo 4 and it's
not happening. So you can decide date, but it
doesn't help. You what does Mike?
Mean it doesn't what? Does Mike say about this?
Does he want it to come out early or he's he's like not not
thinking about it? He's no, he's OK with Enzo 3 is
OK because this market is very specific.
When you have a glider that is competitive, even though it's
old, the peoples are still buying it.
The pilots, I mean they're still buying it because they can see
it's still competitive. That's due to the competition of
your own month. When you have an ENB that is
still competitive, you don't sell it after two years even
though it's still the best ENB on the market, for example.
Yeah, marketing is huge in ENB category.
Man that's like weird to see paragliding.
No, but any any pilot in ENB doesn't have the mean to know
which one is better. You know which one has the best
performance or BV or whatever. So by default they would first
discard anything that is old. Makes sense?
You understand, and a competition pilot doesn't care
if it's old on you. You want the best.
True. So that's the reason why we
don't sell after two years or so and we are pushed to produce a
new model. Look, I've been wanting to ask
this question to you As for a very long time and your your
test pilot and you know, world champion Honoren was on my show
when I started a couple of years ago and he said that the answer
depends on profile. And my question is basically
that you guys came out with shark nose and you decided not
to patented for the greater good for the community to become
safer overall, which was a very selfless move I would say.
And maybe that is karma coming back to you that you have
managed to keep the lead in such big numbers when it comes to
your closest competitor. Time and again we see someone
coming out and say that, hey, I am discovering the technology
which is the shining star of tomorrow.
For example, Swing said rust helps keep the rear edge
deflated. Jin came out with the wave
leading edge after investing crazy amounts of money in the
R&D. So if we collectively did not
have patents in the community, will we be having safer wings or
does it not really matter that much with these technologies
because eventually it's profiled?
No, it doesn't matter. They this this industry is too
small to bother attacking ourselves and trying to make
money with patents. So I mean if you talk about the
rust swing will be very happy that we use the rust in our
gliders and if we use a wave leaning edge gene will not
attack us in any way. We have implemented winglets on
our gliders recently while it was used for edges by Advance.
Fair enough. Coming back to the debate that
is going on, Luke, a lot of people are saying triple C's
should be going away. Do triple C's really need to go
away or do we need to become more responsible and more
structured overall with paperwork, with legislation,
with testing, with, you know, hit and try method?
What what is your take on that? My take is we should make this
triple C evolve in the holes. That's it.
So in also in the scoring in my opinion.
I'm trying to explain that, but it's a long subject.
I cannot explain it here. We don't have the the time I
need to go. I'm sorry.
I see my wife is sending me a lot of what's up.
Very nervous. I understand, Luke.
Well, on that note, yeah man, thank you for coming.
It was a long time in the planning that I wanted to have
this chat with you and I think we have touched upon a lot of
interesting topics here, so whenever.
Yeah. OK.
Welcome. And we could redo one if you
have some other question important.
But sorry for now, I need to go to you soon.
Have a good evening, Luke. See you.
Bye. Bye, bye, bye.